[Applaudissements]
jade est une petite fille de 5 ans vous
savez une de ses petites filles qui
incarne la joie de vivre comme tous les
enfants de son âge
au matin du 25 décembre allez donc
impatiente d'ouvrir ses cadeaux et de
voir si elle a reçu le fameux vélo
qu'elle attendait tant ses parents sous
ses yeux émerveillés
lorsqu'elle ouvre ce pack est immense et
découvrent leur fameux vélos dont elle a
tant rêvé sont ravis au moins autant
ravie qu'elle est là sans réfléchir
elle décide de monter sur le vélo puis
se met à pédaler en chantonnant l'un de
ses airs préférés
ses parents reste sidéré ayant peur de
la chute de leurs enfants
d'un côté mais également étant très
surpris de la voir faire du vélo aussi
parfaitement
d'un autre côté alors même qu'elle
n'avait jamais fait auparavant lorsqu'il
lui demande comment cela se fait qu'elle
en fasse aussi facilement elle leur
répond en toute simplicité
je l' ai tellement imaginé et j'en ai
tellement rêvé que c'est facile
cette petite histoire de jade illustre
parfaitement les bénéfices que peut
apporter
l'évocation mental au quotidien on peut
parler d'imagerie mentale d'imagerie
motrices de visualisation que cette
évocation soit volontaire ou
involontaire
peut-être même que certains d'entre vous
pendant que je racontais cette histoire
se sont surpris à visualiser des images
pour accompagner ma narration
je suis enseignant chercheur à
l'université de lyon et depuis plus de
15 ans je m'intéresse vous l'aurez
compris à ce qui se passe là dedans
quelque chose de fascinant mais travaux
portent sur les représentations mentales
que nous formons et sur les bénéfices
que ces représentations mentales sont
susceptibles d'apporter que ce soit pour
développer des compétences améliorée des
performances ou également récupérer en
cas de blessure ou d'un capacités
motrices
si vous le voulez bien nous allons
pratiquer un petit peu puisque il se
trouve que nous faisons tous
spontanément et quotidiennement un
travail de cette forme on ne formalise
pas forcément passé terme mais nous le
faisons tous à plusieurs reprises au
cours de la journée je vous propose dans
un premier temps de centrer votre
attention sur cette croix au centre de
l'écran un petit peu comme si vous
vouliez rentrer dans une bulle être ici
et maintenant en pleine conscience
écoutez boury de votre silence intérieur
et puis progressivement vous allez
laisser venir à votre esprit
quelques images les images d'un moment
pendant lequel vous avez effectué un
mouvement à la perfection un mouvement
sportif un acte de la vie quotidienne un
acte professionnel peut être comme ce
coup droit au tennis comme un coup de
pinceau sur une toile comme un geste
relativement précis pour atteindre votre
but
peut-être pour certains un plongeon dont
vous êtes excessivement fier pour
rattraper le vase qui allait tomber
lorsque le chien l'a cognée bref un
mouvement que vous effectuez à la
perfection que vous maîtrisez
parfaitement comme si vous aviez eu un
déclic et que vous le fassiez exactement
comme vous devez le faire
laissez les images s'installer et des
filets sous vos yeux
laissez vos sens s'imprégner de cette
expérience accompagner les images de
tous les sons qui étaient présents à ce
moment-là mais également laissé remonter
à vous les émotions les sensations qui
accompagnait ce délicieux moment je sais
ce que vous allez me dire c'est plutôt
agréable et surtout très facile
prenons un deuxième exemple si vous le
voulez bien autorisez vous à vous
projeter dans un événement à venir dans
une situation vous allez vivre dans
quelques jours là encore prenez le temps
de laisser tous les détails de la scène
dans laquelle vous allez vous retrouver
vous imprégner revenir à votre esprit
peut-être est-ce un moment agréable
peut-être une situation plus anxiogène
que vous serez alors capable de
surmonter
prenez le temps d'inspecter ces détails
toutes les informations importantes
comme secondaire nous avons fait un
petit exemple sur le passé nous voulons
faire un petit exemple sur le futur
permettez moi de vous proposer un
dernier exemple sur le présent imaginez
que sur la scène du théâtre de l'opéra
magnifique dans lequel nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui imaginer qu
apparaissent soudainement un chien en
train de faire du vélo le même vélo que
la petite jade a découvert en ouvrant
ses cadeaux à noël un chien tellement
heureux d'être là qui se met à tourner
autour de moi enchaînant des figures
acrobatiques tout plus complexes les
unes que les autres
un chien qui salue son public un chien
qui sourit qui est content d'être là
parmi nous aujourd'hui
n'est ce pas fascinant de se rendre
compte à quel point il est possible de
construire des représentations mentales
de choses pourtant improbable
enfin normalement aussi facilement
c'est quelque chose qui est absolument
déconcertant et encore une fois qui est
relativement spontanée et que l'on fait
au quotidien alors
de nombreuses études scientifiques se
sont penchés sur l'intérêt l'importance
de l'évocation mental de nos pensées
pour essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe pourquoi finalement penser à
quelque chose se concentrer imaginer un
mouvement permet d'améliorer les
performances
il est faux de dire que le cerveau ne
fait pas la différence entre un
mouvement réalisé physiquement et un
mouvement simuler mentalement néanmoins
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ce schéma
imaginé un mouvement et le réaliser
physiquement vont activer des régions du
système nerveux commune
nous pouvons voir sur l'image d'ubs à
toutes les zones qui sont colorés en
bleu correspondent aux zones qui sont à
la fois activée pendant imagerie mentale
pendant la représentation mentale du
mouvement et pendant l'exécution réel de
ce même mouvement
certes la superposition n'est pas
parfaite mais elle est importante
cela signifie que lorsque l'on imagine
un mouvement lorsque l'on se projette
dans la construction d'une
représentation mentale
on va activer les mêmes régions que
celles qui sont responsables du
mouvement
ce sont les réseaux de la préparation de
l'exécution et du contrôle du mouvement
on parle d'équivalence fonctionnelle ou
neuro fonctionnelle entre réalisé et
imaginer et c'est pour cette raison on
le verra que le travail mental va être
particulièrement efficace d'un point de
vue un petit peu plus pratique de
nombreux résultats ont été également mis
en évidence les bénéfices que cela peut
apporter en termes de performance ou
d'apprentissage par exemple parmi ces
exemples cc moi vous présenter une étude
célèbre qui a été réalisé chez les
musiciens les auteurs de ce travail ont
mis en évidence que le fait de
s'entraîner mentalement deux heures par
jour pendant cinq jours sur une séquence
de piano permettait d'arriver à un
niveau de performance significativement
plus élevé qu'un groupe contrôle qui
faisait une activité neutre de durée
équivalente
bien évidemment ceux qui s'entraînent
mentalement vont toujours moins
progressé que ce qui s'entraîne
physiquement on peut le voir en
comparant les deux courbes du bas sur ce
graphique le niveau de performance
atteint par les personnes qui se sont
entraînés mentalement équivaut à peu
près au niveau de performance atteint au
troisième jour dans le groupe qui s'est
entraîné physiquement
autrement dit le fait de s'entraîner
mentalement permet d'atteindre un niveau
de performance au bout de cinq jours qui
équivaut au niveau de performance
atteint par le groupe qui lui s'entraîne
physiquement au bout de trois jours mais
ce qui est très intéressant dans ce
travail c'est qu'en rajoutant simplement
deux heures de pratique physique
supplémentaire au groupe qui s'est
entraîné mentalement alors ils
atteignent un niveau de performances
strictement équivalent au groupe qui
s'est entraîné au total 10 heures en
pratique physique
parallèlement les auteurs ont montré que
la représentation au niveau de la
surface corticale donc dans le cerveau
des muscles concernées par le mouvement
les effecteurs de la main donc
fléchisseur extenseurs des doigts et
bien la taille de ses représentations
augmentait à la surface du cortex
de la même manière selon qu'on
s'entraîne physiquement ou mentalement
c'est prodigieux
ce dernier résultat met en évidence un
principe relativement bien connu est
d'actualité qu'on appelle la plasticité
cérébrale ou neuroplasticité c'est à
dire la capacité étonnante formidable du
cerveau à se réorganiser
il existe différentes formes de
plasticité la première que je
souhaiterais vous illustrez c'est la
plasticité de compensation spontanée
celle qui se met en oeuvre naturellement
spontanément généralement en cas de
lésions ou d'immobilisation prolongée
dans cette vidéo vous allez pouvoir
identifier chez un amputé du membre
supérieur que les régions qui sont
initialement dédié au contrôle de la
motricité et de l'intégration
sensorielle des muscles du bras amputé
ce fonds envahir progressivement par les
régions adjacentes à la surface du
cortex moteur
cet envahissement qui traduit ou qui
reflète la plasticité de conventions
sont spontanées et souvent au moins
partiellement associée aux terribles
douleurs fantômes que vivent ces
patients
dans une étude relativement célèbre chez
cette population
il a été mis en évidence que lorsqu'on
demande aux patients de se pince les
lèvres en même temps qu on scanne leur
activité cérébrale
il active à la fois les régions du
cerveau qui sont responsables ou qui
contrôle la motricité des muscles de la
bouche qui se pince élèves mais
également des mains si encore une fois
on reflet de cette plasticité de
compensation spontanée ce qui est
intéressant dans ce travail c'est
qu'après un entraînement mental de
quelques jours la configuration
d'activation change considérablement
lorsqu'on leur demande après le travail
mental à ces personnes de se pincer les
lèvres alors on a une activation des
régions dédiée au contrôle de la
motricité de la bouche mais plus de la
main c'est la colonne du milieu et vous
pouvez constater par rapport à la
colonne de droite qui correspond à ce
qu'on observe chez des sujets sains
qu'on a quelque chose qui se rapproche
de plus en plus de la configuration
initiale chez ces sujets sains ce tout
dernier résultat met en évidence la
seconde forme de plasticité celle qui va
un petit peu plus nous intéresser qu on
appelle la plasticité activités
dépendantes
c'est à dire celle qui est directement
induite par un travail en l'occurrence
un travail physique ou pour ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui un travail mental
cette seconde forme de plasticité on la
retrouve très fréquemment chez les
sportifs et les musiciens puisque c'est
elle qui va progressivement caractérisé
façonné moduler le cerveau experts dans
cette expérience nous avons demandé à
l'haltérophile français le plus titré
notamment vice champion olympique à
pékin de stimuler mentalement son
mouvement et nous avons enregistré
l'activité cérébrale au cours de son
travail mental
nous avons ensuite comparé ces
activations aux configurations obtenus
chez un sportif débutant qui effectué le
même travail qui s'imaginaient le même
mouvement
sans rentrer dans le détail de des
configurations qui sont représentés ici
ou qui vont apparaître dans cette vidéo
nous pouvons constater assez facilement
que la modulation des activités et la
mélodie jouée par le système nerveux est
très différente en fonction du niveau
d'expertisé
cela caractérise véritablement le
cerveau experts cette capacité grâce à
la pratique progressive de tous les
jours de construire réorganiser en
permanence les connexions des différents
réseaux neuronaux qui sont responsables
des comportements d'intérêt alors quand
on réfléchit un petit peu à tout ça on
se dit c'est finalement pas très
illogique puisque le travail mental
c'est une forme de travail même si on ne
pratique pas l'activité
il ya des informations qui vont
permettre au cerveau de renforcer des
promoteurs ou au contraire de les
modifier
et puis au bout de quelques années avoir
travaillé sur ce domaine là je suis
tombé un jour sur la bd vous connaissez
tous la bd du chat de philippe geluck et
je suis tombé sur un schéma qui
finalement résumé exactement tout ce que
j'étais en train de faire et tout ce
pour quoi je me cassais la tête depuis
un moment on avait le chirac était posée
devant un alter et qu'il regardait et
qui disait tout simplement si je soulève
cet alter je me muscle du biceps mais si
je pense que je soulève je me muscle
cerveau alors s'est dit un petit peu
différemment mais je me suis dit aïe
il a en fait résumé une bonne partie des
choses que j'essaye d'expliquer de
manière peut-être un petit peu plus
complexe mais c'est exactement ça alors
moduler le cerveau pour apprendre
améliorer une performance on a vu que
c'était quelque chose de possible
allons encore un petit peu plus loin est
ce que nos pensées peuvent nous soigner
vous vous en doutez la réponse est oui
et ce à plus d'un titre
il est par exemple très facile de faire
des petits exercices relativement simple
et rapide pour se soustraire de la
douleur et diminuer la sensation de
douleur perçues en cas de blessure ou en
cas de stimulation douloureuse
vous avez ici la schématisation d'un
cerveau d'une personne qui lors d'une
stimulation douloureuse est très
sensible à la douleur c'est le schéma de
gauche et la même stimulation
douloureuse qui se retranscrit par des
activités très différentes chez une
personne à droite qui est beaucoup moins
sensible à la douleur
l'idée du travail mental qui va être
derrière les exercices que nous
à proposer encore une fois des exercices
très simples et très faciles d'accès
c'est en quelque sorte d'éteindre cette
matrice de l'activité neuronale qui
reflète l'interprétation de la douleur
et donc de se rapprocher vers la
configuration que l'on a à droite
en quittant celle que l'on observe à
gauche on peut aller encore un petit peu
plus loin se soustraire à la douleur
s'est bien amélioré la récupération
motrice la récupération fonctionnelle
limiter la perte de force limiter la
perte d'amplitude articulaires c'est
encore mieux vous avez un exemple ici
d'une étude que l'on a faite chez les
patients qui ont subi une chirurgie
réparatrice du genou suite à une rupture
du ligament croisé antérieur
deux groupes ont été effectués un groupe
a suivi un travail mental
un groupe a suivi un travail de
thérapies classiques les deux thérapies
était bien évidemment les mêmes dans les
groupes et vous pouvez voir que
l'activation musculaire enregistrée dans
le quadriceps des patients qui ont suivi
le travail mental c'est la courbe en
bleu remonte beaucoup plus rapidement
que le groupe contrôle qui s'est
contenté entre guillemets de suivre la
rééducation klasnic
autrement dit sont repartis avec un
niveau d'activation musculaire
significativement plus important à
l'issue du protocole c'était une
quinzaine de séances dans quelque chose
de relativement rapide
pris dans leur ensemble ces résultats
mettent en évidence qu'il est possible
grâce à un travail mental qu'il faudra
intégrer le plus rapidement possible
d'ailleurs dans la prise en charge
ebay les caps il est possible de réduire
ou de limiter la perte de force et la
perte d'amplitude articulaires
là encore c'est prodigieux et nous ne
sommes que sur quelques petits exemples
isolés
j'en profite si certains d'entre vous
sont encore en train de voir le chien
sur son vélo tourner autour de moi là ça
va commencer à devenir inquiétant il
faudra peut-être qu'on en parle à la
pause éventuellement pour régler le
problème mais normalement il peut alors
vous vous en doutez ce travail nécessite
une rigueur et un contrôle permanent
il ne suffit pas d'imaginer pour
transformer il va falloir respecter des
règles et des codes de pratiques des
consignes très précises apprivoiser son
mental mais c'est quelque chose
encore une fois que qui reste facile
d'accès qui reste peu coûteux et pas
suffisamment intégré reconnu ou
pratiquer
alors même je le répète que nous le
faisons tous quotidiennement et
spontanément
pourquoi aller chercher des solutions
onéreuses dans des technologies de
pointe que nous ne maîtrisons pas
totalement
alors que nous avons déjà une partie des
solutions une grande partie des
solutions en nous laisser place à votre
imagination
apprivoiser là car elle est sans limite
mais surtout savourer sans les effets
sans modération merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yj